escalating tension and violence in the
Red Sea has prompted a joint statement
from 13 countries including Canada the
US Japan and the UK widely denouncing
the attacks which they say threaten
innocent lives from around the world
calling the attacks quote illegal
unacceptable and profoundly
destabilizing with a warning that the
yemen-based houthi will bear the
consequences if they
continue this comes after us warships
San several houthi vessels killing 10
people in recent days the houthis are
Iran aligned Rebels who have launched
drone and missile attacks on Commercial
boats since mid November targeting what
they say are ships linked to Israel amid
its bombardment of Gaza following the
October 7th Hamas attacks several
shipping companies including some of the
biggest names in the industry have
suspended or limited operations through
the Red Sea contributing to delays and
soaring costs nearly 15% of marine trade
flows through the Red Sea including 8%
of grain trade 10% of oil that travels
by sea and 15% of natural gas military
vessels from the US UK and Iran have
increased their presence this disruption
is most acutely being felt in Europe
Asia and the Middle East now the retail
Council of Canada tells Global News it's
closely monitoring the situation and the
Canadian Chamber of Commerce warns of a
domino effect according to IMF data for
today the average ship movements in the
area are down approximately 42%
year-over-year and while Canada operates
few vessels in the affected area uh the
interconnected nature of International
Supply chains means that disruptions
have a potential knock on effect for the
Canadian economy late last year the
price of oil spiked as Red Sea attacks
intensified this year though Traders see
an economic downturn keeping prices
muted but that can change the Bank of
Canada FL the situation as one to watch
because if things persist or get worse
it may eventually drive up inflation
across Canada an gaviola Global News
Toronto